magic it's pretty amazing and I had the
two best guys in the world so I'm really
happy that was last May now Megan Marco
and Prince Harry's son Archie is
celebrating his first birthday and et is
taking a look back at five of the cutest
moments from his big first year at
number five newborn Archie meeting his
great-grandmother Queen Elizabeth it'll
be a nice moment to introduce the baby
to the Moore family and mom's with us
another great Megan and Harry made the
introduction shortly after giving the
world our first glimpse of their bundle
of joy they later shared the sweet photo
on their Sussex Royal Instagram account
and revealed his name in the caption
quote the Duke and Duchess of Sussex are
pleased to announce they have named
their firstborn child
Archie Harrison mountbatten-windsor we
just purchased our Thrones I have our
little bundle of joy
to spend some precious times with him is
insane study starts to grow our number
four moment is the first time Megan and
Harry gave us a glimpse of Archie space
the couple posted this adorable photo of
the newborn gripping and peeking over
Harry's finger in honor of the 35 year
olds first Father's Day he waited for a
very long time to become a father there
were moments when he feared he never
would become a dad so to mark father's
day with baby Archie is going to be
really special this little thing is
absolutely to die for so I'm just over
the moon at number three
Archie's first public playdate with his
cousins George Charlotte and Louie the
photos of Megan and sister-in-law Kate
Middleton hanging out with their kids at
a july 2019 polo tournament or
everything he has the sweetest
temperament was really
[Music]
the dream Archie was only 2 months old
at the time but he seemed cool as a
cucumber as Megan cradled him while
cheering on his Papa Harry and uncle
Prince William coming in at number 2 is
this precious father/son moment in
Canada to feel your excitement for a son
in addition to spending the holidays on
Vancouver Island the Sussex is also
stayed there earlier this year in
between announcing their plans to step
down as senior Royals and officially
making their royal exit on March 31st
well I would step my family back from
all I have ever known to stick is to
take a step forward into what I hope can
be a more peaceful life the photo was
part of Megan and Harry's end-of-year
montage looking back on 2019
one look at Archie's eyes and smile and
there's no denying the family
resemblance she's already got a little
bit of facial hair as well and finally
our number 1 Archie moment is when he
joined his famous parents on their royal
tour of Africa last fall baby Archie is
the youngest member of the British royal
family to carry out such an ambitious
long haul overseas tour you know I think
for us it's just been a really special
trip our Archie sightings might have
been few and far between
I think the schedule they've been very
kind to me because everything is based
on Archie's few times now so it's a full
plate but we're making it work it's
worth it
[Music]
but watching the little guy interacting
with his parents while meeting with the
Archbishop Desmond Tutu is too cute for
words and we learned this about Archie's
personality royal expert Katie Nichol
recently gave us an update on how the
youngest Sussex is progressing but he's
bubbling and and so desperate to to talk
but suddenly already mastered cruising
and is well on his way to walk it happy
first birthday to Archie
[Music]